[Musique]
ambiance à l'américaine en plein cœur de
plaisir ce jour-là ils sont près de 150
passionnés munis de leur chapeau et de
leur Santiag pour danser la country pour
les accompagner les musiciens de rocking
chair et c'est le partage entre les
élèves entre tout le monde nous est
bénévole et on partage notre savoir et
on partage toutes les soirées ensemble
et ça c'est génial celle qui est à
l'initiative de ce rendez-vous c'est
elle Lili Levallois véritable enfant des
western elle a créé cowboy add dancer en
2009 pour partager sa passion
aujourd'hui l'association compte 52
adhérents a des gens qui viennent de
chartre aussi qui viennent de toute la
région parisienne du 95 du 60 de partout
ça plaît énormément on commence jeune et
on finit on a j'ai eu des personnes qui
avaient 78 ans jusqu'à 78 ans et des
jeunes de 6 ans donc vous voyez tous les
es tous les âges se retrouvent autour de
la danse country une activité que tout
le monde peut pratiquer c'est l'ambiance
les
amis on fait travailler la tête on fait
travailler les jambes de la joie parce
que c'est et en plus on a un petit
groupe de copains donc c'est bien
franchement c'est dynamique et si vous
voulez bouger venez ici depuis plusieurs
années suscite un véritable engouement
selon un sondage hiop publié en 2019 4
millions de personnes de plus de 18 ans
l'ont déjà pratiqué au moins une fois en
club la çaésente une certaine liberté
quand même voilà c'est la liberté la
conviabilité et puis connaître du monde
voilà c'est comme une famille si vous
aussi vous souhaitez découvrir la
country cowboy addcer propose une
adhésion de 170
€
[Applaudissements]
ci